on va proposer pas d'être inhumain de
faire en sorte de vouloir
particulièrement mettre les seniors au
travail c'est l'application de la
réforme Touraine on travaille 43 ans
quand vous voyez vous avez commencé à 20
ans vous travaillez 43 ans mais quand
vous avez commencé à travailler à 22 ans
vous travaillez jusque Canac jusque 65
ans c'est la réforme Touraine les
faitages effectivement il peut avoir
aussi un effet mais je voudrais qu'on
soit clair entre nous très clair entre
nous c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans d'où
au travail supplémentaire soi-disant de
62 à 64 non non c'est l'ajustement des
bornes et effectivement de par la
réforme Touraine certains seront ou
certaines seront amenés à travailler
plus longtemps et d'autres par les faits
de l'âge légal seront à travailler
quelques mois également plus longtemps
peut-être années pour certaines
générations mais c'est pas deux ans de
plus pour tout le monde arrêtez de
vendre un argument qui est faux parce
qu'effectivement ça contribue à mettre
les gens dans la rue mais si on leur
explique bien la différence elle est
quand même importante
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je ne suis pas le bourreau
des seniors que vous prétendez que je
sois